[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGELA GOSZ: Good
afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to the
2:20 breakout session,
Improving the Patient
Experience with Cloud Endpoints.
My name is Angela
Gosz, and since this
is a health care
dedicated breakout today
and since we are at Google Cloud
Next in the midst of 35,000
people in a two and a half
block radius and in health care,
we're focused on
wellness, I would
be remiss as a certified
yoga instructor
not to take us through a
quick moment of mindfulness.
So if everyone wants to just
get into a comfortable seat
in your chairs and sit up
straight or find some comfort.
Let's take a quick
inhale through the nose.
And an open mouth exhale.
Did that feel good?
I'm getting some head nods.
Excellent.
Let's do it one more
time just for fun.
Ready?
Inhale through the nose.
And exhale through the mouth.
Wonderful.
Thank you for indulging me, and
hopefully that was good for you
too.
OK, quick housekeeping
note for today's session.
In case this is anyone's first
breakout at the conference,
this year we're doing something
a little bit different.
And we brought our Dory
platform to the conference.
Dory is a platform that we
use internally here at Google
for questions and answers.
So if you want, you can
open up the Next app,
click on the session
that we're in today,
Improving the Patient
Experience with Cloud Endpoints.
Click on the Dory link.
And then you can
type in any question
throughout this session today.
One of the unique
features about Dory
is that you can actually
upvote or downvote questions
if you also happen to
have that question.
And if you type in the answer
and we don't get to it,
or I'm sorry, the
question and we
don't get to it by the
end of the session,
I can personally assure you that
myself or someone from my team
will actually
answer that question
by the end of the week.
So just want make
sure everyone feels
that they have the opportunity.
And with that,
let's get started.
So it's fair to say that
the cloud transition has
fundamentally changed
the way that we
live in our personal lives.
Did anyone take a Lyft
or an Uber on the way
to the conference today?
I see a lot of hands.
Did anyone use Google
Maps to plan their trip
to San Francisco?
Lot of hands.
Awesome.
Did anyone use entertainment
apps like Netflix or Spotify
to enjoy entertainment
on the way here?
Excellent.
And what is one thing that all
of these apps have in common?
They allow instant access
to data, no matter what
device you're logging in from.
And through this access
to instant information
in our personal lives, it's
also increased our expectations
of how we expect technology
to work in our work lives.
Well, the same is
true in health care.
Today's caregivers and patients
alike are cloud natives,
and they expect to be
able to use technology
to give better care and increase
face time with their patients
or receive better care
and have more face
time with their doctors
through the use of technology.
More wired, consumer oriented,
and innovative than ever
before, the health
care industry is
and has been undergoing
profound transformation.
Starting to cater to
one click experiences,
health care is starting to
look like other industries
and a truly consumer driven
industry or marketplace is
taking shape.
Patients are gravitating
toward providers
who are meeting these
higher digital expectations.
And the good news is that
when providers invest--
Accenture actually
recently posted
that providers can boost
margins by as much as 50%
in meeting patients'
expectations.
On the flip side,
providers are more and more
reporting feelings of burnout.
Has anyone here heard
about physician burnout?
Yes, we have heard about it.
I actually went to an event for
the American Heart Association
in Chicago on Saturday
night and the chairperson
of the organization referenced
this exact same statistic.
In that example, the
goal of the organization
was to acknowledge
the burnout and take
in more mindful practices
to reduce stress
of care providers, ultimately
lowering the potential
for heart disease.
In our case here
today, we're talking
about how we can
leverage technology
to reduce some of those
experiences of burnout.
The thing is, as most of
you raised your hand today,
health IT and health
leadership has heard this.
They know that patients want
more from their technology
and that providers
also want that help
to increase face time.
But the challenge is
managing and delivering
on those expectations while
increasing or maintaining
security and reducing
the cost of care.
In the third quarter
alone of 2018,
4.4 million patient
records were compromised
in 117 different data breaches.
That's staggering.
And increasingly, every year
that studies are coming out,
the top concern
of US hospitals is
reducing the cost of care while
meeting financial targets.
So most everyone agrees that
things can be done better,
specifically in the areas of
better integration, better
support, better training,
increased security,
and of course, lowered cost.
Here at Google
Cloud, we would offer
that the key to
security and simplicity
can be found in our cloud.
Through it, you can find
an increase in access
to information so that providers
are not spending as much time
looking for the data and
spending more time giving care.
Reduce operational
costs, increase security,
and protect the PHI,
and fight the cyber
attacks that are coming out.
This is the same
technology that we're
offering that Google
uses internally
as our own organization.
Just keeping that in mind.
And also offering better value.
Imagine being able to perform
clinical duties in the morning
and then go on hospital
rounds in the afternoon
and log in from home to access
your data from any device
or location that
you might be in.
This would mean that you
might have the access
to give better time and
potentially treat situations
as they arise.
Transformation for
your organization
could look like any
time anywhere fast
access to patient information,
be it web, mobile,
or other legacy
based application.
Reduced cost and
complexity, specifically
in the face of budget cuts
and funding uncertainties.
Better insights to
drive decision making,
helping out with
the goal to improve
population health through
IoT and big data analytics.
Stronger information security
and improved access to patient
care, be it through
retail clinic, telehealth,
home monitoring, or
other virtual option.
Meeting patients where they
are and ultimately giving them
a better feeling of care.
Chrome Enterprise
is the best choice
to put the power of the cloud
in your provider's hands
and ultimately improve
the patient experience.
For your health
care organization,
this solution is
secure by design.
With a multi-layered
approach to security,
it includes comprehensive
AI driven threat protection,
automatic updates, verified
boot, and the ability
to wipe lost or stolen
devices within minutes.
It's easy to share and manage.
The management console comes
with 200 plus security policies
that you can provision at
the user or the device level
so that you can control
and curate the end user
experience of choice.
And through the seamlessness
of the management console,
you're able to manage hundreds,
if not thousands, of devices
with a very lean IT staff.
And we do have some studies
out there I would definitely
encourage you to check out.
And it's a smart investment.
By increasing end
user productivity
and reducing operational costs.
For your health
care practitioner,
Chrome Enterprise
is a great solution
because it provides ready access
to health care apps and VDI.
So whatever application
your care provider
needs to deliver to
the end user patient,
Chrome is able to
help you do that.
Additionally, it's a fast
and familiar interface
that's as easy as
navigating a browser.
One of my favorite things
about Chrome OS as an end user
is that these devices
boot within six seconds,
and they come out of
standby in three seconds.
Which if you can
think about the course
of your day and every
time that you log in,
log out, restart your
computer, that cuts down
on a lot of downtime.
And additionally, with
the automatic updates,
you don't have to wait.
Your system is going to
restart in four minutes,
and you get that notification.
Updates happen seamlessly
in the background.
And finally, a
variety of devices
help meet end users where they
are to perform any function.
So we have in our
form factor options
the Chromebook, which is
our notebook offering.
We also have tablets
and two in ones.
We have the Chromebox, which
is our desktop offering,
and a Chromebase,
which is an all in one.
And these are available
through all of the major OEMs
that you're already
working with.
Companies like Acer,
AOpen, HP, Dell, Lenovo.
Go ahead and check out
what their Chrome solution
looks like.
And for your patient, Chrome
offers autonomous access
to information.
So they can access their data
instantly and from wherever
they might be.
It also increases face
time with a provider
while they are at
a facility, and it
provides a feeling of more
personalized care when
the face time is increased
between the physician
and the patient.
In its Total Economic Impact
Model, Forrester ran a study
and found the following results.
In a composite organization
of 50,000 users
using 15,000 Chromebooks and
averaging 10 devices per user
over a three year period of
time, these were the results.
$1.5 million in hardware
and software cost avoidance.
$3.5 million worth of
employee productivity gained.
75% improvement in
IT productivity.
And $50,000 saved per device
when remotely disabled
in the event of loss or theft.
These are great numbers.
And you might be thinking,
wow, Angela, that's awesome.
But how does it affect
my organization?
Well, I would encourage you to
Google Chrome Enterprise TCO,
and you'll find our friends
at ESG actually put together
a calculator for
us so that you can
put in all of your own inputs,
including the number of end
users that you have,
the type of job
function that they are, whether
it's front line or knowledge
worker, the productivity
software that they use,
and there are some other
questions to follow as well.
So definitely check this out
as a resource after the session
today.
We also have a robust
ecosystem of partners.
So Chrome was
invented 10 years ago.
And today it's the number
one leveraged platform
in the education space.
Well, on the journey
over the last 10 years
and people finding out about
Chrome through this growth,
they've said, hey
Google, can Chrome
do this for my organization?
And over time, Google
listened, and every time
that a customer asked and
we were able to deliver,
we created unique partnerships
with these organizations.
And so today we
are able to deliver
on a great deal of clinical
workflow for your organization.
Calling out to
such partnerships,
which are basically
mission critical for us
at this point in time,
Citrix and VMware.
The reason why these
partnerships are so strategic
is because largely today, the
major EHR companies, Electronic
Health Record, which is the
number one thing where care
is given from, where information
is input to and accessed from,
are typically
still legacy based.
We probably will see a
migration to the cloud
at some point for those
organizations in the future.
But for today, through our
partnerships with these VDI
organizations, we're able
to deliver EHR through VDI
on the Chrome platform.
So Chrome Enterprise improves
the patient experience
in the following ways.
It's helping the health
care practitioner
through a variety
of form factors
instantly access information,
reducing some of that burnout,
and helping their patients
a little bit better.
From the patient
experience, patients
have more access to
information and more face time
with their doctors, which gives
them a better sense of care.
And finally, customer service.
By helping through
different use cases,
both on the front line
and backup house support,
patients feel that
they're cared for
and they're able to get their
questions answered quickly.
So now that we talked about
how the solution works,
let's talk about what some of
the actual use cases for Chrome
and health care looks like
and what some of our customers
are doing today, starting with
the mobile health care worker.
In this use case,
we're typically
deploying Chrome in
a one to one capacity
on a tablet, a Chromebook, or a
two in one convertible device.
And this really looks like the
clinical plus knowledge worker
hybrid solution or
mobile VDI, if you will.
And again, all of
the major OEMs,
you can find one of those
form factors from them.
One thing that we used
to hear is that's great
and I'm really
liking the solution,
but I need for the provider
to be able to work even when
they're not on a Wi-Fi network.
And the good news is that
we do have LTE options
in the hardware portfolio
today so that you can have
that connectivity at any time.
Shared workstations.
So this looks like
clinical workflow.
Multiple people are
sharing one device.
It might be in a hallway, in an
exam room, on a medical cart.
That could be in an all in one,
on a Chromebox or a Chromebook.
And the wonderful news
here is that we're
able to complete clinical
workflow and the shared user
workspace through
our partnerships
with Imprivata and HealthCast.
So where that badge tap
and go is concerned,
we actually do have a demo of
it at the health care industry
breakout on that side
of the showcase floor.
So definitely encourage
you to check out
what our shared
workstation use case looks
like after the session today.
Digitize training
and communications.
Fun fact, training
is a common use case
where a lot of customers start
their journey with Chrome.
The reason for that is because,
typically, training departments
have a smaller pool
of devices that
are in a siloed environment.
And so that silo creates
a more palatable situation
to run a POC and pilot.
And a fun fact for you, as well,
or an anecdote, I should say.
One of our customers
from Wisconsin
actually worked with us at
HIMSS19 in Orlando in February
and shared that in
their training use case,
they were preparing
for incoming residents
for the next educational season.
And they, by their own measure,
saved 150 hours in time
from not having to image
devices but rather enroll them
into the management console.
So they felt like those
were really great results.
And as such, they
have now started
to look at Chrome
for other use cases.
And finally, temporary staff.
Has anyone here ever forgotten
their laptop at work?
Couple of people.
I actually did it two weeks ago.
I was really embarrassed.
But the great news
is that Google has
a solution called grab and go.
And our IT department
created it a while ago.
And the reason why they did
it was to help with end user
productivity uptime.
So in our grab and
go solution, which
we are demoing at the
Chrome Enterprise breakout
in the workplace transformation
space, what happens
is that an end user will go
to a hardware kiosk, which
is available through one of
our hardware-- or our partners.
And they check out the device,
log in through their cloud base
profile, and they're
up and running
for the day or the
week, if they're
visiting another location.
And then once they're
done, they simply
log out and return the
device to the hardware kiosk.
Now, you might be
thinking, well,
what does that actually mean?
Notice in this situation
that I just described,
there was no provisioning
required by IT for that end
user to start doing their
job, which meant that they
were able to start immediately.
And there was no
de-provisioning time
needed for the IT
department, which
means that the end user
experienced more uptime
or access to their information
and the IT department
won because they did not have to
serve that particular incident.
So grab and go is a
wonderful solution.
And maybe you have health
care vendors that you serve
or other people that
rotate in and out
throughout your facility.
So definitely check this out
at the workplace transformation
booth.
Moving over to the
patient facing use case.
We have two examples
to talk through today.
The first being self-service.
In the self-service
use case, this
is where we're talking about
kiosks being used for patient
check in and check
out, to take surveys,
to verify address
information, insurance.
When the patient is able
to do this on their own,
that saves on administrative
time from back office staff,
freeing them up to
do other things.
And it also is nice
for the patient,
because they're in
more direct control
of their own information.
And then finally, the in room
entertainment and information
use case.
This might look like a
tablet at the bedside.
It might look like a Chromebook
being used in a waiting area.
Or it might look like a
Chromebox attached to a monitor
in a hospital room.
And in this particular use
case, a patient facing app
would be delivered
to the patient
so that they have
more direct access
to their own information.
Lab results, the list of their
clinic visits, different things
that they would want to have
access to about their care plan
or about their treatment
or having access
to directly communicate
with their care provider.
So there are
multiple applications
available for this today.
But where it comes
in intersection
with Chrome is that
at the end of 2017,
we started to deploy the Google
Play Store across all Chrome OS
devices.
And just like we
talked about how
we leveraged these entertainment
apps for our own use on the way
to San Francisco
this week, patients
are still people at
the end of the day.
And they want to be
able to be people
and to access
different information.
So through the Google
Play Store on Chrome OS,
you're able to deliver
some of those applications
like Netflix, like Spotify
for entertainment use
and help through some of
those feelings of anxiety
that they might be feeling.
So with that said, you
just heard a lot from me
about how Chrome
Enterprise works.
I'm going to turn it
over to Jason Tahaney
from Hunterdon Health, who
is a current Chrome customer.
So he can tell you about
their Chrome journey.
Jason?
JASON TAHANEY:
Thank you, Angela.
Hey, good afternoon, everyone.
So I'm going
apologize in advance.
I'm from New Jersey, and we
don't have the hills that we
have here in San Francisco.
We have mere foothills
compared to this,
and I also took up running
about two years ago
and I thought I was all that
kind of running last night
and my knees are not quite
what they used to be.
So if I go crashing down, please
it's for no other health reason
other than I was
stupid yesterday.
So anyway, so I'm Jason Tahaney.
I'm the Director of IT
for Hunterdon Health.
And a little bit about
Hunterdon Healthcare system.
We are a community hospital
with a very far reach.
We have about 75
physician practices.
We are founded in 1946.
Literally the miracle
in the cornfield.
We raised a whole bunch
of money a long time ago.
And part of the Hunterdon
Healthcare system.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit, as Angela mentioned,
about some of the Google
products that we use
and we've found to really be
powerful for our organization.
So in health care, we
really have some serious IT
challenges.
We have legacy applications.
So unless you're
one of the lucky few
and you can afford some of
the really large EMR systems,
you're left with about
eight or nine different EMRs
in your health system.
A lot of them are
code based that
was developed back in the '90s.
I mean, I know that's for us.
We have some of the--
some of our EMRs
are just really that ancient.
And not to mention even if you
have some of the larger EMRs,
you still need surgical
systems and you
need things like nutritional
management systems.
I mean, really complex
to run a hospital.
So lots of legacy applications.
And then because of
legacy applications,
partially, we have data silos.
So we end up with
information kind
of all over the place across
different-- in different EMRs.
We try to tie it up
together with something
called the interface engine.
And it works, but not really
quite that seamless integration
that we all would like to see.
I mean, some of our
newer standards with FHIR
that are coming out are
going to kind of hopefully
help with some of those issues.
And then we have rising costs.
So I think I read, as of
2012, it's about $377 billion
in costs of inpatient health
care in the United States.
That's just inpatient.
That's a whole lot of money.
Regulatory environments.
So we ask everyone here,
if you're in health care,
you know what HIPAA is.
Security and privacy rules.
Security rules, how we protect
the privacy of our patients.
We also have things
like PCI if you
take financial transactions.
A whole lot of PCI compliance
that you need to do.
Basically if you're doing
business with credit cards,
you need to be
compliant with PCI.
And we have limited
skills where to start.
So I have lots of talent, great
teams, but not enough of them.
So we really look to, like
others, looking to the cloud.
How can we leverage cloud?
We picked Google Cloud, and
I've been pleasantly surprised.
Very happy with
the product so far.
So a little bit about
the solution, health
care in the cloud for us.
Chrome Enterprise is
at the center of that.
And that's everything from the
Chrome browser on the desktop
that we standardize to things
like Chromebooks, Chromeboxes,
the meeting room
boxes as well that we
use that we're starting to use.
We also use Docs and Sheets,
which are your Word and Excel
replacements.
And really, Google did
a nice job with that.
They're kind of one
of the first ones
to have that real time
collaboration in Docs
and Sheets.
And we took advantage of
that early and very powerful.
Team Drive.
Another great one
for if you want
to replace your SharePoint
[INAUDIBLE] SharePoint product.
We had about 40 different
SharePoint sites out there.
When we moved to Team Drive, we
were able to consolidate that.
And we put Team Drive
together with sites.
Then you can either do a very
nice intranet application
or have the same functionality
as SharePoint, essentially.
Alert Center.
You can't do any
kind of presentation,
especially in health
care, without talking
about cybersecurity.
So the nice thing
about Alert Center
is it's across all the
entire Google platform,
all the products you're using.
It's kind of that
alerting to tell you,
hey, something's going
wrong, whether it's
on your mobile device,
of suspicious activity
on a mobile device, to something
going on in the Chrome browser.
It's kind of all the
things as a consumer
that you see out there when
you connect from a trusted
computer.
Do you trust this
computer or not?
So that's what this is
for your enterprise.
So the solutions expanded.
So I talked a little bit about
the SharePoint sites and silos.
Team Drive and Google
Sites really working out
very well for us there.
We were able to
consolidate and get rid
of our SharePoint footprint.
Legacy applications.
So we have to support
these applications.
And kind of how do we
do that with Chrome?
And the nice thing,
what I like about Chrome
is it's a modern
operating system.
Really a cloud based
But we can still tie it to some
of the traditional ways of how
we used to do things with VDI or
Virtual Desktop Infrastructure.
So plug into your provider.
Google pretty much supports it.
We are a VMware
Horizon customer,
and it works very
well with that.
Although it works
with Citrix as well.
And we found that as very nice.
So we've been able to kind
of put Chrome devices out
there and still provide access
to our legacy applications.
Multiple collaboration tools.
So things like what I
didn't mention on the slide
before, Google
Meet and Hangouts.
So Meet is your
Webex replacement.
It can be used for training,
video conferencing.
Really nice.
And the great thing
about it is it
comes with when you get the
suite, Google Suite, which
I also have mentioned Gmail.
So our journey started
with Gmail and G Suite.
But it's all part of suite.
When you use that, you get
Google Meet and Hangouts.
So very nice tools that we've
been able take advantage of.
On the regulatory
side, it doesn't
get any more important than
the security piece of this.
What's nice is the security
[INAUDIBLE] in Chrome OS.
So we can put them out there
without needing expensive tools
to manage them.
So they're encrypted
by default. You
can use the Google Console
to manage all that.
And I mean, even for things
like software deployment,
you don't have to go out and get
a separate tool of the software
deployment to your
chrome devices.
And we found there's
a reduction in cost
there, because we don't need
those expensive tools anymore.
So easy patching on
the Chrome browser.
Angela mentioned that.
It's auto patching.
It really is true.
I was pleasantly
surprised by this.
Another tool that
we needed to kind
of patch our
Windows environment.
Not needed in the
Chrome environment.
It is self patching,
and it really does work.
So on the rising costs.
We estimated about $400 to
$600 per Chromebook deployed.
And that's because
you don't have
kind of the expensive
cost of your Microsoft
licensing for Office
and things like that.
And along with email, Gmail
did a nice, great cost savings
for us.
And they're easy
to use products.
I mean, they really are.
You can really put
them out there.
When we went live with
Gmail and G Suite,
we did all the training
to our organization.
We did all those
kinds of things.
But to be honest, they had
seen the product already
in their kind of consumer life.
So it really helped
with that transition.
And we found that it's been
an evolutionary process
since then.
We just kind put it out there,
and folks just start to use it.
It's been a great thing.
So Google Cloud
increased productivity.
It's easy to use.
It is budget friendly.
Secure out of the box and does
provide better collaboration.
All the tools are very tightly
integrated and very powerful
when you use it as a platform.
So a little bit of
a case study here.
In New Jersey back in 2017,
the state required us to do--
they put out a New
Jersey early intervention
system for child development.
So the goal of
this was the catch
developmental
disabilities in children
early in the patient's home.
And they put this progress
no tracking system out there.
They required our
clinicians to use it.
We had to use it
in about 30 days.
So our director of
child development
kind of came to me in
a panic saying, hey,
we need devices
to get out there.
We need to do this in 30 days.
How are we going to do it?
So we were able to do
it with Chromebooks.
So it was amazing
how fast we were
able to deploy it since
they're secure out of the box.
it was a web based application.
It had everything
that they needed.
And we were able to
get it out there.
And then it was very tightly
integrated with our legacy
applications as well.
We provided access to Windows
applications through VDI.
And it had G Suite and
Chromebook or anything else
that they needed to use.
So kind of a nice story
there and still working out
very well.
And always a good thing when
we're helping out children.
So we talked about
cybersecurity and privacy.
And this slide really is about
the security piece of this.
I mean, I think back in 2016,
Verizon put a report out.
90% of the breaches that happen
out there start with email.
So the G Suite, Gmail
itself very powerful.
We do a lot.
I mean, the email
security AI is incredible.
You get these products kind
of right out of the gate.
So things like attachment
sandbox and protection
against 0 day threats.
So that's basically
a piece of malware
out there that nobody
knows how to fix.
And this is technology that's
put out there for Google
to try to catch it, really,
without any kind of pattern
or any kind of traditional
signature based technology.
When we talking about protecting
patient health information,
encryption at rest is huge.
For us, we knew we
needed to do this.
We just could not do
it in our data center.
I mean, the cost for us
to encrypt everything
that we have in our data center
was really off the charts.
Not really feasible.
So you get this
by default. And I
think I heard that Google's
one of the only ones
that in their cloud environment
they provide encryption
by default. So that
was very powerful.
Encrypting data at rest.
We were able to do,
around regulatory,
the secure, hardened
Chrome OS environment works
very well for our clinicians.
And what's nice is the
security, it just kind of works.
It doesn't get in the way of
the provider or the clinician
providing care, which is always
a good thing in security.
The other big factor for us
on the business associate side
for HIPAA.
If you're going to do
business with health care,
you really have to sign
a business associate.
So Google does sign HIPAA
business associate agreements.
And that was a key
one for us early
on when we were
looking at G Suite
probably about six
or seven years ago.
They weren't quite there yet,
but now they are doing that.
So very powerful.
Strong regulatory compliance.
Advanced threat protection.
Cloud based security
that is always improving.
I mean, you get these things
without thinking about it.
The features just
kind of come out.
You do have to turn them on.
But we truly have seen, at
least on the Google side,
we've seen the power of cloud
on Google and getting features
turned on kind of
right away, especially
in the security part of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]